Luke Cage season 2 follows the titular
character on his journey to take down
Mariah shades and Bushmaster
as with all Netflix Marvel series there
are a couple of things to unpack from
the finale and throughout this video I
will be dissecting the end of the season
as well as what could happen in season 3
there will be several spoilers so if you
don't want the showroom for you now's
the time to turn off you have been
warned with that out the way I'm
definition and this is my ending
explained video for Luke Cage season 2
the defeat of bushmaster throughout
season two we see that the antagonist
Bushmaster possesses similar powers to
Luke Cage his bulletproof skin gives him
a huge advantage when invading Harlem
and this eases his quest for revenge
unlike Cage Bushmaster uses a powerful
nightshade compound to get
super-strength and bulletproof
protection
coming to Harlem to destroy Mariah
because her family double-crossed his he
sets out on a quest for revenge sneaking
into haarlem's paradise through a tunnel
from prohibition which Mariah's door a
tilde has told him about he seeks to
murder Mariah once and for all but Luke
intervenes Luke chokes out bushmaster as
Mariah screams kill him
however Luke sees misty who urges him to
stop Bushmaster escapes and pleas
through the tunnel again before the
police can apprehend it learning that
the nightshade has taken a toll on his
body he flees to Jamaica
where he is able to use a lower dosage
till the Tulsa's and Ingrid that you
will need rest and a medication made
from nightshade which can only be found
in nine-mile that jamaica while she may
return in future seasons I personally
think that the character will remain
there due to the medication and the fact
that mariah is now dead shades shades
and Mariah share a strange relationship
throughout season two and this comes to
a head during the finale horrified that
Mariah murdered so many people during
the Rompin
massacre shades decides to cooperate
with Misty's investigation against the
queen of Harlem this grant him immunity
from persecution and even know Luke
views this as a power play shades
confirms that he has now been labeled a
snitch so will not be able to progress
within the market however after Mariah
dies when her daughter kisses her on the
lips with a poison laced lipstick his
immunity becomes null and void
this is due to the fact that it was
reliant on Mariah being convicted
therefore Shades has arrested by misty
for the murders that he confessed to
whether or not he stays in prison
remains to be seen
however shades could return in season
three as an adversary or even has an
unlikely ally it will be interesting to
see how the characters are progresses
and I can't wait to see what happens to
him in the future the sheriff of Harlem
in a shocking twist Luke takes over
Harlan's paradise and follows in the
footsteps of cottonmouth and Mariah left
his inheritance to Luke Mariah believed
that the club would sway the character's
morality and turn him into an overlord
much in the same way that she was in
order to stop at another crime lord
taking Mariah's place
Luke fills the role but claims himself
as the sheriff of Harlem in an attempt
to distance himself from what came
before
however Luke's friends had disturbed by
his willingness to take Harlan's
paradise and negotiate with crime lords
when Luke says he plans to make Harlem
great again his friend DW accuses Luke
of becoming a Luke Trump and this really
highlights the moral dilemma that Luke
now faces the W buys pops barbershop
telling Luke that it will once again be
neutral ground and misty informs him
that he's on a slippery slope because
she knows that just because Mariah gave
him it doesn't mean that he has to take
it Luke tells her that you will be able
to maintain order this way but misty
warns him that she won't hesitate to
take him down sugar who now works for
Luke tells him that Claire has returned
but it remains to be seen if actress
rosario Dawson will reprise the role in
next season personally I believe the
sheriff of Harlem position will put them
at odds with other characters from
Marvel you
I predict a third season that may see
appearances from the likes of Jessica
Jones and daredevil whether they will be
friends there to try and steer them back
on course or take him down as enemies
remains to be seen but I cannot wait to
see how this progresses down the line so
what did you think of Luke Cage season
two how do you rank here against the
other Netflix Marvel TV show and what
would you like to see in season three
comment below and let me know and if
you'd like to see more of my ending
explain videos then please subscribe to
my channel I release videos like this
weekly and they'll definitely be
something on here that you love recently
I discussed Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom so please check that out at the
end of this video again thanks very much
for taking the time to watch this and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]